Cole miles Gary B here continuing the
conversation really appreciate you guys
jumping in and and making a fair offer
I've seen gone up to 1950
I started 200 you went to five g's I
countered with 1,700
you went to 1950 voice I don't know if
you saw last night but my New York Jets
and seem to be your New York Jets pulled
out a huge victory stunning fashion even
I just can't understand why you wouldn't
want to be a part of that and I got to
be honest with you I really told you and
wanted you guys to accept the 1700 you
felt the need to counter offer and I'm a
little bit disappointed with that and to
be very honest with you I do not feel
and this is what do you think about
negotiations I don't feel that you guys
are in the saddle here I don't think
you're on the right side of this
negotiation I definitely do want you to
be Japan but thousands of people have
been emailing me and tweeting at me
saying that they will take less and thus
even though it's a lunch box full of
cash I'm going to have to rescind my
offer since you didn't accept it and now
I'm offering $1,200 in cash that's just
the way it is boys miles Co I love you
guys I love you guys but $1200 is still
six hundred dollars each and if you pay
attention to the way negotiations are
going I demand that you guys pass my
accept my offer because $600 each still
get you a boat motor stuff like you guys
said transparently you're not bad into
football this is not a big lift for you
six hundred cash is huge and I highly
recommend you take it because if you
come back with another video with
another negotiation I may continue to go
in the wrong direction